I will shoot the movie basketball yeah
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] man which one which
moved in a screwball I come to town and
they send me the 20th Century Fox yeah
and they tell and they go go and go my
pretty blue
I got NYPD Blue you baggages nine pages
Spanish English I can't cut this I'm
walking back as I'm walking lady pops
angles are you here for the audition
yeah she looks at me there and she gives
me the sides you can learn them and come
back in five minutes I go but I don't
know nothing about that
Marc Maron Marc Maron not even a school
play yeah okay
I go in I don't move up I read thank you
for coming in all right but my god I'm
living in a hotel and Schrader there's a
hostel
uh-huh it's now it's now a hostel and
then it was $27 a day got a three-week
limit SRO oh my god I would go there
every night with you have a hot plate no
I just stayed on Hollywood Boulevard and
got malaria and everything else that
comes with [ __ ] I lived in that place
because you could only live for 3 weeks
of the shot yeah some of the different
tools go on the road ten days go on the
road right here this this is 90 [ __ ]
seven yeah and when they call it was
like a rocky hotel yeah some who goes
there a jelly deer not always on a whole
pay phone in the hallway you Joey Diaz
yeah you got a call downstairs over long
enough to pick up the phone like a man
it's your manager Ken Phelps what's up
Ken listen I got a you got the bull do
bass ketball talk because yeah it's
three weeks 5,500 a week or you losin
about 55 one in the back of my mind I'm
like that's a mouse 50 is [ __ ] grand
everything that you could talk about
heal up when you're sucking when you and
don't blow it yeah somebody talk to you
like how much you paid 250 really cool
you can make a complaint you know but
every time with some amount of cocaine
at mass figure so I get when you hear
50,000 almost 5500 for three weeks but
there was a catch how to pay for my own
sag a PA got them to [ __ ] waive the
fee or cap Hartley and - oh no pay your
move the princes paid it
right in those days they would talk to
Paducah money I gotta pay the patinas a
new kid on the block Jesus boom they put
me in that dog I was a I was on 24-hour
medicine because I'm economy ya know
this - wait
yeah much more too much are you father
Yemi trailer
yeah practicing roller skate yeah so
eventually the street we came now what
do you think I started doing steel
roller skates from the big trucks we had
a big truck they had like 18 pairs of 13
thank you you're waiting the shoe and
that's the on row every night I'm taking
a pair of rollerskates
take out the ski chalet three bills put
sex I'm taking back cash every bit of it
since I had to wait till one guy got off
one guy got back on everyday they
finally do it like what the little
easier on top of 5,500 a week yeah
topless and not even gonna check it yet
and that I'm living about 15 dollar
checks and living at a hospital you know
and all sudden I'm stealing rollerskates
I would listen but and now there's like
ten other guys telling the story from
the other side we had this guy oh my god
his name was Joe stealing [ __ ] skates
every night thinking no one knew it oh
my god i relent until they only I like
up the slice yeah